good afternoon my name is Amy Makris I'm
the coordinator of Technology and
culture forum at MIT and the Episcopal
chaplain at MIT and it's my good fortune
to welcome all of you to this forum this
afternoon here in the Bartos theater at
MIT it's been our good fortune at
technology and culture forum to
co-sponsor this two-part series on the
campaign and the media with the
communications forum at MIT and with the
Center for the Future Civic Media and
I'm very thankful for the great work
that the staff at both both places have
put into putting the series together as
many of you know this is the second of a
two-part series and we first gathered
here to discuss the campaign in the
media at the end of September with
another wonderful panel and at that time
we had a tremendous discussion about a
lot of aspects of this issue some of the
things that stood out for me in in that
discussion which will probably continue
as themes tonight are first of all what
media are breaking stories around the
campaign and how much of the news about
the elections that we see in the media
is actual reportage and how much is
simply talk or commentary on the facts
and does it matter does it matter
whether the media are breaking stories
and how that happens do people really
care about the facts when they go to the
polls or is their vote based on
something else we also talked at that
first forum about Obama's campaign and
it's very savvy tactics using new media
and whether that was going to make a
difference especially in terms of
getting out the vote among younger
voters and what the long term
implications of those techniques and
that strategy would be and finally we
talked about whether or not and the
extent to which new media are having a
significant impact on election politics
and on the election process so tonight
we're on the other side of the election
and I'm glad about that I don't know
about you it was quiet quite a
and I'm glad it's resolved now and we
are standing on the other side of it and
able to look back on the events of
election day and see from our
perspective now how the campaign and the
media came together so tonight we have a
tremendous panel to guide us in this
discussion and I'd like to tell you just
a little bit about each of the people up
front we have Ian Rowe who's the vice
president of strategic partnerships and
public affairs for MTV ian oversees
MTV's on-air online and off air
pro-social campaigns you notice think TV
and his work includes the 2008 choose or
lose campaign he's been referred to as
the conscience of M of MTV you can tell
us whether that's true or not
prior to MTV he worked with the USA
Freedom Corps at the White House the
president's initiative on volunteer
service so welcome Ian Rowe to MIT
sitting next to Ian we have mark and
bender an associate editor at the
Atlantic and a contributing editor to
both the hotline and national journal
mark was the editor of hotline on-call a
path breaking political news blog and he
was one of the founders of ABC's the
note his latest writings can be found on
the mark M bender blog which he may be
familiar with
so welcome mark ambit er to MIT and next
mark is Cyrus Crone the director of the
Republican National Committee's a
campaign so Cyrus was formerly the
publisher and co-founder of Slate
Magazine and prior to joining Microsoft
he was he produced programs for CNN
including Larry King Live and crossfire
so welcome to you as well welcome Cyrus
moderating the discussion tonight is
Henry Jenkins Henry Jenkins is the
co-director of the comparative Media
Studies program at MIT and the Peter de
florins professor of humanities at MIT
he's the author of convergence culture
were old and new media collide and many
other great books on media and popular
culture so tonight Henry will moderate
our discussion and we're gonna go I
think until 7 o'clock if the if folks
have lots of questions there'll be time
after after the discussion up front
there'll be lots of time for all of you
to ask questions and make comments so
when we get to that point there'll be
microphones and the aisles and professor
Jenkins will invite you forward to to
offer your thoughts and your questions
to this great panel so with that turn it
over to Henry Jenkins happy happy to see
everyone out there today
you know I said ever since I came to MIT
20 years ago we've been organizing these
forums on democracy and new media
through the communication forum event
and every year going into the election
cycle we hear pundits say this is going
to be the one this is the one that
digital media is going to transform
American society this is the one where
power of old media gives way to the
power of new media and then the election
ends whatever dramatic spectacular
events take place and the pundits then
say oops I guess we were wrong new media
didn't make that much difference anyway
it really was old media and it's agendas
that set the tone for this campaign now
mind you these are pundants speaking
through old media for the most part
who've decided that new media didn't
matter terribly much but it's been a
repeated cycle and I my own theory has
been that they really are looking for
them the digital equivalent of the
Kennedy Nixon debate the problem is the
Canadian Nexen debate is a March typical
example of broadcast media its power was
people all over the country watching the
same event at the same moment in time
rather than the dispersed decentralized
social networking effects that are
associated with new media as it has its
impact new media is never going to be
felt in that concentrated way
that of something like Kennedy Nixon
debate represented well I hope we can do
today though is to dig deeper into the
myth and reality of the role of new
media in this last election cycle to
sort of see how what these three experts
have to say about the role that new
media played and to see if we can come
or at least agree on some criteria that
would help us to think more deeply about
the role of new media as I do what I
think we have to dispel the myth that
it's about simply new media and that it
really is very much about the
relationship of old and new media that
we that one has to think about as we go
forward so what I want to do is begin by
having each of the people in the panel
sort of introduce we have introduction
just tell us what you've been up to for
the last 12 months you've been out there
dealing with the thick of this thing
from different vantage points so why
don't you just give as tell us a little
about yourself and what you've been
doing so again why don't you start us
off just a piece of information our
research folks sent us I think is so
illustrative of what we've been through
so we have a group of 18 to 22 year olds
all across the country it's sort of our
private audience community they were
constantly asking them about a whole
range of issues and of course related to
the election we asked them so tell us
three brands that really you associate
with Obama versus McCain you know just
to get a sense of you know how young
people are positioning these two and
with Obama the three brands were Apple
innovative you know Nike excellence and
coca-cola someone sturdy you know all
sort of top-tier brands with John McCain
the brands were Exxon Mobil Tommy
Hilfiger and bet and bengay and I think
that's a it's funny but it's so elective
of how our audience I think absorbed
both of these both of these candidates
as folks that you know I I have the job
at MTV which is all about how to
how to use the power of our brand to
engage young people and some of the the
biggest issues facing their generation
so we've done a lot of work around
issues like HIV global poverty
discrimination global warming but we
clearly discovered way back in 1992 that
the political process particularly
presidential politics was a mystery to
most young people in that they rarely
felt that presidential candidates were
speaking to them about the issues that
really mattered to them were speaking to
them in a language that they could
understand presidential candidates
assumed young people weren't going to
vote this terrible cycle and so we
decided to step in back in 1992 to
create a campaign called choose or lose
which solely existed for the purpose of
mobilizing young people to understand
the issues to register to vote and
really get candidates to speak to 18 to
29 year olds and so 1992 1996 2000 2004
so it's it's been a it's been a business
we've been in now for some time and
while everyone I think really was
looking like this year Obama the
phenomenon you know we've been seeing an
incredible upward swing since 2004 that
young people have just been coming out
in big big numbers in 2004 they're
almost four million more 18 to 29 year
olds that voted than in the year 2000
and then in 2006 in terms of
congressional midterm elections it was
the highest turnout in more than two
decades so we were fully anticipating
that come 2008 we would see big big
numbers and again in the in the
presidential primaries turnout was
double quadruple and quadruple in some
states and so we we saw that there was
this phenomena occurring and clearly and
and really been more than 12 months we
started our you know presidential
coverage essentially back in February of
2007 there's just it's just we have
never ever started a presidential
campaign I mean in fact usually we start
our presidential campaign coverage of
chooser lose in February of the elect
year so we were fully a year before just
given the incredible level of interest
from our audience and we also obviously
had started to see the explosion in
tools that young people were using in
every other aspect of their life you
know the idea that they could now self
publish and self organize around what
mattered to them whether it be music or
hanging out with their friends why
wouldn't they do that around social
issues and presidential politics and so
this whole idea of we were gonna have a
national election but there are a lot of
young people that were really interested
in local issues because in many states
many cities who your local alderman is
mayor may have a lot more influence over
your life than necessarily who the
president was and so we saw with all
these new technologies we saw an
opportunity to partner with the knight
Foundation around something called their
night news challenge where we created an
idea called street team oh eight where
we had 51 journalists one from each
state and DC whose sole job it was all
year long to report on issues of
importance to young people within their
given state and to really you know use
all the technologies whether it be and
I'll have a short video they'll play
right now use mobile technologies use
online use Twitter the the basic premise
was go to where young people are already
and that we don't care where the media
is consumed but just reach them where
they are and it was just and again we'll
talk about it more was a phenomenal
experience to see these 51 report over
the course of the year and made with
that thought I'll and we'll show the
video and tons more to tons more to talk
about yes we all knew this election was
going to be different
there's the explosion and we all knew
this election was going to be different
there's the explosion and turnout at the
Iowa caucuses and a movement among young
voters in particular unlike anything
we've seen before and of course some
history-making candidates from the
get-go but there was also a new way of
covering the election the technology
that had just begun the revolutionized
politics in 2004 had gone viral
reporting or some version of it had
become decentralized networked and more
mobile than ever high definition and
formality took a backseat to immediacy
and intimacy for the YouTube generation
street team o8 was just one such
experiment 51 young amateur News hounds
representing every state in the District
of Columbia some with journalism degrees
most not so much gathered in New York
City for a two-day crash course in
videography and journalists ethics and
then we were turned loose into the wild
we were to cover national news from a
local perspective and vice versa and all
through the eyes of young voters from
stump speeches in Georgia all the way
the stump speeches in Washington State
from showing how national issues affect
local young voters $600 travels a lot
farther in West Virginia than it would
in other states therefore there's a good
chance that Mountaineers might be more
prudent with their cash somewhat
defeating the purpose of this economic
stimulus bill I would use $600 to pay
for rent to sharing our community
stories with the national audience I
think that our vote can really count now
because a lot of people are really
embracing indigenous culture and
indigenous ways people who aren't
indigenous they they look they look upon
our people as as people who have always
known it and paying particular attention
to one of our most important issues this
year the plight of our young veterans
and it just got worse and I end up my
having a relapse I ended up actually
getting behind the wheel of a car you
know after I've been drinking I got into
a wreck and I got the boot that's how I
got out that was a Marine Corps infantry
in Iraq as a veteran I know it was
difficult for me when I came out of the
military trying to be a civilian again I
had to fight and scrape and pander the
government to get me the things that I
rape and for the most part not paying
nearly as much attention to Paris Hilton
as you might think instead of talking
about cheap celebrity drama let's talk
about our not so cheap four hundred and
eighty two billion dollar projected
budget deficit for 2009 a new record bTW
we also tried to push the edge of the
reporting envelope in ways only our
technological generation can on Super
Tuesday we used video enabled cell
phones to cover almost every primary
state throughout the day streaming live
video from the phones to our website and
from there to the cable network we even
got one very elusive future VP candidate
on one of our cell phones
this is the cool thing I can talk about
involvement by Americans having to say
and where this nation's kind of goes I
need a and for a last night you know I
hopefully register on somebody's radar
screen yeah I think they're on our radar
now we did it again for the conventions
although by this time we were hardly
alone in Denver and Minneapolis on the
inside and Minneapolis on the outside
gasps people gasping people here guests
coming down
trying to get away my nostrils are
burning soon my eyes are starting to
water local national on the ground on
the web and mobile talking to young
voters as young voters where they are
this is politics in 2008 is an
improvement don't know yet but I bet
2012 is gonna be crazy back to Paris
Hilton I remember the good old days when
the budget deficit actually was four
hundred eighty billion in tech the
national debt increased by four hundred
eighty billion or so in October alone
but I have had the privilege of doing
journalism in a new media format mostly
on on the blog for one of the oldest
most established old media brands in the
country namely the Atlantic which was
founded more than 150 years ago as a
clarion call to the nation to fight
against slavery an addition to that I
was also a consultant for CBS News so it
really gave me a good mash of old media
and new media perspectives I just want
to tell one very brief story about a
story that I think illustrates a little
bit the moment that we're in it doesn't
make me look very good but about a week
before the election John a Barack
Obama's national field director John
Carson sent an email to several thousand
obama supporters who were living in
arizona and the email said you know our
internal polling shows that Arizona is a
really close race we want to try and see
if we can increase our field efforts
there we want to get people to volunteer
somebody who received that email
forwarded it along to me I thought it
was a fairly it wasn't it's not a huge
story but I thought it was a fairly
interesting example of what the Obama
campaign was doing and week before the
election and of course illustrating even
if they were fake
in a sense that they thought Arizona was
competitive so I put the email on my
blog I stripped out what I thought were
all the identifying information of the
person who received the email but what I
didn't realize is that every email that
the Obama campaign sent out included
embedded hidden geocoding that so that
the the link the volunteer leaked if you
wanted to volunteer even though it was
it seemed fairly generic it was
something like Barack Obama comm slash
Arizona every time you click through
that link it would send a message to the
Obama campaign central servers showing
exactly whose email had been used had
been used to facilitate that link so of
course in journalism you never want to
reveal your sources and again this
wasn't something terribly huge but the
the poor guy who sent me
who-who-who forwarded me the email
suddenly got lots of ribbing and teasing
emails from Obama people asking why he
had forwarded me afforded me the email
so again it's sort of an example of how
I think even the practices of modern
journalism haven't necessarily caught up
with new media technology so I'm happy
to talk about that and lots of other
things
well I stumbled into this election cycle
someone accidentally I I spent 10 years
at Microsoft and then went to Yahoo and
was at Yahoo for two years and my job
with both companies was to help
politicians figuring out how to use
those companies products to influence
elections as an example you know working
with Mitt Romney on a video mashup tool
called jump cut that Yahoo had acquired
working with campaigns to geocode their
Flickr photos and understand how that
worked
I spent the bulk of my time helping
senator Obama and Senator Clinton think
about how to integrate themselves into
these networks and I grew up a
Republican I'm an army brat traveled
around
the world from military base to military
base and really with my core interest is
the intersection of Technology and
politics and how the world is evolving
but never did I think that I'd actually
be a part of a campaign and one day I
got a call from a friend who used to
work at the Republican National
Committee and said they need somebody
that understands technology are you
interested and I reflected on sort of
what I was doing at that time and it was
basically spending the majority of at
helping senator Obama and Senator
Clinton and at that point decided that
if I was really gonna be in this
election I may as well jump in
wholeheartedly and went back to my party
and moved across country and had a
really fascinating experience the last
20 months so let's jump right into the
core issue of the panel I like to start
with sort of broad first principles so
if we were gonna make an argument one
way or another about the impact of new
media on this election cycle what are
the criteria we would use what in what
way it would not did new media make a
difference I think we can agree it did
but in what ways did it make a
difference I'm just gonna say one thing
that I think you saw right at the
beginning of this cycle was a lot of old
media platforms using new media
technologies and essentially adopting
the rhetorical styles and and the style
of new media and essentially trying as
large conglomerates and corporation do
to sort of muscle in on the territory of
independent new media so I think you at
first have to make a distinction between
independent new media and then the the
new media that was generated by the old
meat I mean you had a publication for
example like the Politico which was or
and is a fascinating example of a of a
new medium startup that was that was
originated by an old media corporation
in in Virginia and really made a huge
impact and
a lot of stories and so on and so forth
so I think you have to make you have to
make that distinction first yeah I mean
I would say you know sort of brass tacks
I think the number one criteria that you
would look at is who voted and how many
you know we have know about 24 million
18 to 29 year olds voted which again if
you it was about again close to a four
million person increase from from 2004
we are strongly strongly believe that
that is a big fat and 70 percent of
those nearly 70% of those voted for
senator Obama which was the largest gap
ever between two candidates within our
generation we're convinced that has a
big part of that is his use of new media
and and how he used it I mean it's it's
just extraordinary and it's a a lot of
folks talk about and is very bottom up
it was actually I we believe very
centralized but decentralized process
you know this this idea that everyone
had sort of part ownership of his brand
it's so interesting right that you
talked earlier about you know facts you
know did people care you know one things
about the internet not only does it
allow greater distribution of
information allows greater distribution
of misinformation but even that Senator
Obama mastered and probably most folks
saw this website that they created
called fight the smears calm which we
just thought was incredible I mean here
was a site that was set up for the
deliberate purpose of highlighting a lot
of the internet rumors that heretofore
usually were used to destroy a campaign
and yet it was used as a vehicle to give
his supporters away to be active in the
campaign so are you going there yeah
it's fight the smears calm and the power
of it is it literally lists in a very
user friendly way all the most terrible
rumors about Senator Obama he's a
socialist he's a terrorist he wasn't
actually
in Hawaii what else there well he's a
Muslim and the beauty of this was that
it highlighted and said you know what
get the facts so you could go to this
website learn the truth from the
perspective of Senator Obama but most
importantly on the left hand side if you
scroll down a little bit there's a
little widget that you could put on your
Facebook page or your MySpace page help
us spread the truth so so then you
became an ally in Senate Obama to
preserve and protect his brand so every
single person had a role to play in his
campaign which is this level of thinking
you know if you go to many of his
YouTube pages where all his videos were
there you had the ability to actually
donate to his campaign all of these very
subtle but incredibly powerful and viral
mechanisms to give every single person a
way to actually engage so so no longer
this idea of just being a passive
supporter you could give money but if
you couldn't give money you could
organize local beat ups if you go to my
Barack Obama calm you can find you know
local initiatives that were happening
and it wasn't that Senator McCain wasn't
using these I think over time they
finally started to adopt these tools but
just the level of precision and thought
that had gone before with senator Obama
I just think set up a foundation that
just ultimately it was just not they
couldn't cover the gap well I I'd be
remiss if I didn't provide some
historical context and the evolution of
Technology and presidential campaigns
and if we can harken back to the 2004
election GOP team leader which was the
first development in trying to create a
social network and environment to
congregate the electorate was really I
think if you go back and look the the
first true example that the Obama
campaign revved on so I think the the
media cycle didn't really discounted the
background that the party had and you
know
so this was the the bush-cheney team
that had developed this the the McCain
campaign had a much different version
and that basically developed brand-new
code instead of building on top of GOP
team leader but I'm not sure well at
least from from my vantage point we
won't know the true impact of the
election for our party moving forward
until about another 45 days from now and
that's because we've been doing some
database work to analyze the impact of
the internet to turn out the vote and
try to determine if that was the sole
mechanism for influencing voters
decisions and it's very difficult to
create a control group where the
Internet's the sole determinant because
you're being barraged by so many
different media types the closest
example we were able to get to that was
in Louisiana during bobby Jindal's
gubernatorial race where we had taken
our database I should just back up a
little bit and give you some context on
our database voter vault we have a voter
file of every voter in the country if
imbedding tracking code and emails you
know scares you knowing how much
information we have in our database
about voter behavior in terms of
purchasing habits decision-making
magazines that you subscribe to cars
that you've purchased etc we can build a
pretty complex profile of voters and
there's a company called catalyst on the
Left who's doing this they hired the
they hired the CTO of Amazon to develop
their database and I'm not quite sure
that they're at parity with the
Republicans yet in their database
technology but the long and short of it
is we we took our database and we
overlaid it on top of major publishers
databases and we're able to identify
voters nationwide by party affiliation
and flag those individuals so that we
could then target succinct messages to
them at the household level and in the
Jindal campaign we served all sorts of
different online media types to voters
capturing their PII data
then after the election went and
analyzed the Secretary of State's roles
and determined that of the voters who
clicked on one of our banner ads and
gave us their information 76% of them
voted compared to 48% statewide turnout
so the Delta there is significant in
terms of what we were able to understand
about the Internet what we don't know
yet is at the nationwide level how that
same strategy impacted voters going to
the polls and I guess I'm able to answer
that question more thoroughly in a month
and a half but you can sign up I see you
with some of you with computers I'm on
Facebook Twitter or wherever just let's
link up and I'll give you the results so
you're basically saying is Barack Obama
would have won even more had it not been
for voter vault's technology something
like I wanted but no but I actually want
to I want to bring that back because we
are all technological fetishists here
but but we should go back to first
principles which is that the Bush
campaign in 2004 and the Obama campaign
in 2008 I think we're successful in part
because they both managed to use tried
and tested old media marketing
techniques and merge them with with
technology you know one of the and one
of the simplest insights of persuasion
or research on persuasion is simply that
people are more likely to respond to
people who look like them have
lifestyles like them so the Bush
campaign in 2004 organized its volunteer
canvassing around what they called
affinity groups people in certain areas
who owned guns would would would make
good canvas they'd go to make door
knocks or they telephone or they'd send
mail to either directly or via email to
people who also in guns in the same area
the Democrats in 2004 just did not have
the capacity to do that
well the Obama campaign with 630 million
dollars and very rapid technological
advancement I mean this the you know the
the period that it may be interesting to
see whether Democrats did catch up to
Republicans because both sides sort of
keep their
their cards as close to the best as
possible even after the election so
you're not quite sure but what the Obama
campaign was able to do is marry the
technology the economies of scale and
modern marketing techniques so they had
and they brag about an email database of
of just the Obama campaign alone of ten
million people about four million of
those people are actually just email
addresses and zip codes and the dirty
little secret is that the Obama campaign
was only able to figure out any that 85%
of who those people are so they don't
know who so because it's not the easiest
thing in the world to marry somebody's
email to their identity so that leaves
six million people left about three
million of them were contributors about
two million of them were active
volunteers that means they actually did
things through the variety of Barack
Obama websites and on Election Day they
had a million people using their
technologies which which again is again
something to think about the economy of
scale and they just had the money and
the technological resources to to do
that but they absolutely did build on
what the Republican the Republican
effort was in in 2004 and just to give
one concrete example about it you had a
place like Warren Michigan which is the
birthplace of the the the Reagan
Democrats where a Democratic pollster
Stanley greenberg famously did his
polling and sort of limbed out this
group of people called Reagan Democrats
traditionally Democrats weren't able to
figure out how to send for example if if
the target was a 53 year old mother of
two the Democrats didn't have the
resources to send to that person's home
or may have the person making the
telephone call you know a mother of two
who was in her 50s this cycle they could
do that and again this is an insight
that Republicans had earlier than the
Democrats and they have the resources to
put put it in a reality and this cycle
the Obama campaign had those resources
and that's I think part of the part of
part of the reason I think I think it's
part of the part of the answer to the
question I mean there's so many
different parts but I think that's part
of it
just point on that I think one of the
other interesting things that's happened
since really Howard Dean's use of
technology is data ownership and really
controlling that I mean when you look at
meetup comm and the fact that all of
that data was third party owned now with
API is etc the ability to distribute via
widgets etcetera and and then collect
and disseminate and parse that
information makes it so much more
powerful right both both parties used
for example Facebook applications to be
very easy on Facebook if you wanted to
make phone calls on behalf of John
McCain or I think the I think the McCain
campaign did this you can tell me if
they did Barack Obama you could just
within five or six minutes you would get
a list of people who you could start
calling again the the the the efficiency
of that sort of get out the voter origin
of the vote but persuasion is something
that this country has really has really
never seen well what was going on behind
the scenes in the social networks I
think far outweigh the value of the
actual interaction on the networks
themselves as an example you've probably
heard of a company in Southern
California called rap leaf social
network data mining organization and the
fact that we could send them information
from our voter file and then they would
spit back a spreadsheet with the
individuals who matched that we're on
had a public profile on a social network
but then the ability to extend that out
into that individuals group of friends
that had public profiles on networks for
targeting purposes was just a gold mine
and it was unbelievable what you could
actually get to communicate with
eventually know what magazines I
subscribe to I mean if you log into
voter vault you could see that I
subscribe to X Y & Z well that would
come from the point I was just making
was really more about the social network
right but I'm just seriously the ability
to find I mean the the there's just I
guess the peer-to-peer aspect of it but
the fact that you're able to figure out
precisely who someone is and who they
who they hang around with who they're
likely tagging around with who they're
likely to influence from multiple
sources whether you're mining from
social networks or acquiring data
through data resellers and and this
isn't unique to the Republicans or
Democrats having through catalyst it
does that privacy issue we live in such
an interesting world right now yeah you
know people thought Microsoft was bad
and now we're seeing what Google Earth
can achieve I don't know where the
privacy lines are anymore yeah that's
good well that's coming at this question
from another angle which constituencies
were influenced most directly by new
media clearly much of the media stories
been about young voters but I suspect
there are also other constituencies that
you that new media tactics have been
engaging apart from mapping all voters
or are there specific things for
specific groups that we can point to in
this cycle yeah a couple examples well I
and one thing I think we should
certainly stress is that you know new
media technology strengthened a
candidate who had a phenomenal and
consistent message I think sometimes we
give too much credit to the technology
and you know there's there's an overall
strategy that exists and then you figure
out the best tools to use you know to
really deploy to engage your audience
and so for example you know in the case
of one example with Obama this whole
idea of a new kind of governance new
kind of government a new kind of way of
listening to your audience so there was
some some particular legislation and
there was a FISA legislation speaking of
privacy issues that over the course of
the early part of the campaign he had a
pre had a position that pretty much
allied with a more left position was
anti-bush but after he won the
nomination he basically took a different
position on this particular piece of
legislation
and there was a revolt on my
barackobama.com literally thousands and
thousands of his supporters created a
group complaining
saying he'd he'd been a traitor he'd you
know now you've won the nomination
you've gone back on your word and to the
point where he had to go on to this
particular group and started blogging to
give his rationale as to why he had
changed his particular position on this
piece of legislation so this was a
particular constituency very concerned
around privacy issues had been in his
camp but really thought you know what
maybe we should because at that time
there was still some issues around
Hillary Clinton and maybe she wouldn't
pull out but I think it sent a huge
message that he basically said look
you're gonna have to agree to disagree
on this one but here's why I've changed
my position and I think that message
again both candidates could have used
this technology it's no big deal to
create now a community space but he used
it in a whole new way to actually
acknowledge a constituency that was very
important to him and had a lot of
influence over other constituencies but
again his use of the technology I
thought reinforced his overall message
that this is a new kind of governance a
new kind of way to bring you into the
political process and how I as a
candidate and ultimately as a president
and I really hope we we do get to the
point to talk about how do we think all
of this affects how he's going to govern
as president but again the technology
sometimes given too much credit how it
fits into an overall strategy and how it
reinforces the message that he sent I
think that's a that's a great example of
how a particular constituency I think
was strengthened at a point where really
could have gone south for Senator Obama
I agree with that wholeheartedly and
technology's a commodity and it's the
cachet and persona of the candidate
that's gonna drive the use of it
I was I was daunted by the amount of
user-generated content that was
generated in support of Obama and you
know you can rattle him off whether it
was will.i.am or Obama girl or so on so
on so on and you know the one piece of
that one piece of media that generated
the most buzz around the McCain campaign
or the McCain girls and that was
actually something done by The
Huffington Post that it took a couple of
days I think people
figure out that it was there was a
parody so you know I think that had a
lot to do with just the psyche of the
youth attraction because this is where
they're consuming their their media and
had such a presence there I want to talk
a little bit about the Obama campaign's
efforts in the african-american
community using both old media and new
media at various points in South
Carolina the campaign noticed that there
was a resistance among older African act
for African American women to Obama's
candidacy this was before I should say
Obama won one Iowa and that changed a
lot a lot of things but there was a
resistance and a lot of the resistance
was centered around the idea that that
he couldn't win and that the historical
moment just it just you know African
Americans had at times been so close to
the dream and had always been taken away
from them so the Obama campaign MS
Michelle Obama had done several very
successful speeches speaking directly to
this subject and in order to reach older
african-american women in South Carolina
the Obama campaign created VHS cassette
tapes and CDs and they went to what they
called the B & B circuit which is the
barber shop and beauty and beauty salon
circuit and literally they would have
volunteers go into barbershops and
beauty salons with with with DVD players
or miniature televisions and they played
the speech from from Michelle Obama and
they credit and they they did this a lot
and volunteers spent tens of thousands
of hours doing this and they credit they
credit this use of of old media in part
with helping to loosen some of that
resistance an example of how new media
the the Obama campaign used new media
one of the the goals of the Obama
campaign early on was to increase
African American early vote African
Americans historically have some
resistance in part because of the legacy
of of of a you know of shenanigans and
pull sites to early voting in person and
the Obama campaign was determined to
change this and and post-election exit
polls and services they were very
successful at this but one of the things
that they did was constant
was was do a lot of voter registration
and then as the early voting cycles
began they were able to monitor through
their their data web data warehouse
called catalyst because catalyst was
able to figure out from the Secretary of
State's office exactly who would request
it or who because you could once you
vote your name is has checked on the
voter rolls they could update that
nightly so they bomb the campaign could
see exactly who had voted early and who
hadn't and if you were one of their
targeted supporters and you hadn't voted
early you would get either an email or a
telephone call saying hey maybe today is
a good time to vote if you want our help
we can send a fan to help pick you up if
you didn't vote that day they would get
the information when catalyst and say
hey maybe tomorrow you can come you can
go do it
so again just just a an example of how
they were they were able to use both old
media technologies and new media
technologies to fulfill some of their
specific goals and it's those it's those
examples and internal learning that will
has forever changed politics and
campaigning you know I I'm the director
of what we refer to as the II campaign
division people used to mock me because
they say well it's the internet well
actually I now think each campaign is
more apropos because it's not the
internet its mobile and it's everything
else so maybe it's that that has come
but that the the point I wanted to make
is that you know I oversee a division
whose responsibility is telling about
technology but over the course of the
last year and a half every division
within the organization became dependent
on us in some way shape or form to begin
to evolve their methodology whether it
was the finance department of the
political department or the strategy
department I think that at this point
when resumes come in if it doesn't have
C++ or you know Java on it they may be a
political person but they're gonna need
to have those skill sets as well so
hybrid employ high hybrid skills gonna
be critical I think for any division
moving forward so so far we've been
focusing on the successes of digital
media but or there must also be
downsides
roll that new media played in selection
we already talked about smears whether
we're talking about the idea that Obama
is a Muslim or whether we're talking
about Sarah Palin banning Harry Potter
both of which are in case any when the
rooms confused both false statements
that circulated pretty freely this
notion of unreliable information is real
one I got an email from a multiple
copies of an email from a leading
intellectual media scholars about a
story about Republican kids questions
about Obama and it turns out if you
traced it back it went to a particular
church website that turned out to be a
parody of a church website so the joke
for the Republic the the joke of the
expensive Republican it was the
gullibility of Republicans the joke that
I got out of it was reading the
gullibility of my liberal friends who
also were incapable of seeing the
difference between a parody and a
reality so those seem to be emblematic
to me of still some issues we have as we
broaden who gets to circulate media are
there implications about the reliability
and Trust and are there other issues
people are arguing new media is making
us more partisan that the blogosphere
creates a more divided electorate with
very little chances of the kind of
purple state strategies which both Obama
and McCain began the campaign cycle with
to work so what do you guys see is the
limits or the the challenges we face as
we look at this new Mediascape in this
election cycle yeah I would say that
there are definitely huge risks I mean
it's you know my my mother-in-law I will
say you know her entire internet and
linear experience is essentially FoxNews
redstate.com Drudge Report and forget
this uh right wing bloggers like her her
world's view is very informed but
clearly from a particular perspective
and it's true I mean you can you can
operate and completely I think in Barack
Obama said one
look if I watch Fox News - I think I'm a
Muslim you know I mean this this you
know this this this if that's how you're
sort of consuming information so it's
possible I think ultimately we do have
to trust what I think overall did happen
which is that people diversified their
media sources and we're able to get to
the truth I mean yes there's more
misinformation out there but they're
more vetted resources that if someone
does take the time you can actually find
the correct story I mean in terms of in
terms of you know you know mistakes of
new media yes this whole idea of
misinformation but the biggest mistake
is not understanding how to make that
work for you again fight the smears was
powerful because he turned a huge
negative into an incredible positive
because again he gave every single
supporter a way to support the campaign
with Sarah Palin it was interesting when
she first came out these rumors just
instantaneously went across the internet
you know her her child or in fact you
know the her you know first was revealed
that her 17 year old was pregnant and
then that her baby
that she thought presumably it just had
was someone else's baby like these
rumors spread like wildfire and unlike
what senator Obama did with fight the
smears there actually wasn't really an
effective counter-attack to use it as an
opportunity to say look you know cuz
she's I think in her case she's played
the victim role very well and said look
we're being attacked we're being
vilified these this is the campaign of
these are the supporters of Barack Obama
who's supposed to be changing politics
look what he's done and I'm just you
know like you it could have been
actually an incredible opportunity for
the Republicans it's again change a
negative into a vast positive I mean
none of this stuff was inevitable it was
not inevitable that Obama achieved such
a massive level of support amongst young
people and and winning the election I I
think it again it's I think it's part of
an overall strategy in in 2000 fall of
2007 you know we did our first big event
with Senator Obama then about a month
later we did our first big event with
senator
we partnered with MySpace we put both
them on the channel with something
called a presidential dialogue where we
had literally millions of young people
watching online on-air all
simultaneously the ability to submit
questions real-time polling so as a
candidate answered a question the
audience was responding and saying you
know what we don't like that answer and
then that information fed back into the
questioning RIA and both candidates did
extremely well and we were really
excited because we thought we'd reach a
threshold where we'd really be able to
get both campaigns to have sort of an
ongoing relationship and we spend a lot
of time with Senator Obama getting their
profiles set up and all the things that
they were doing on Facebook and and
YouTube and we and it was somewhat
painful but we got Senator McCain to set
up their profile but it's amazing from
that point forward we revert I mean the
Obama camp would literally literally
updating their profile constantly new
information events coming up new
messages new policy papers constantly
reaching out to their audience giving
tools that their audience could use and
it was like extract you know pulling
teeth with the McCain campaign so again
it's the usage of the technology this
was not inevitable and I think there's
just sort of a presumption that Obama is
a younger guy representative of the the
demo it was it was just sort of in the
bag and it just didn't have to be that
way it I think a lot of it was just
strategic decision-making and lack of
decision-making defend Republicans a
little bit I do think I do think to some
extent it was oh no just just a little
bit I mean I do think to some extent it
wasn't inevitable but given the choices
it was it was fairly inevitable I mean
that John McCain represents a different
a different generation and conception of
America than where most young Americans
young Americans are so it doesn't
necessarily follow that the McCain
campaign should have spent the same
amount of effort on some of the stuff
but just to talk about the Palin example
and defend McCain campaign a bit McCain
campaign set up a huge team of
researchers and lawyers initially to try
and defend Sarah Palin from from
some of the on inaccurate information
that was was going about but part part
of the problem was that as someone who
was involved in the effort told me a
they couldn't keep track of what
everyone was saying because it was
coming fast and furious be there was
enough truth in a lot of what was what
they were saying that they couldn't they
had a hard time convincing people that
certain things were true and certain
things weren't the other thing is when
you're someone like Sarah Palin and have
never really been a national public
figure no matter how hard you try in
this age of of instantaneous information
and YouTube you cannot you cannot
competently vet someone who has not been
in the public eye and expect them from
from day one to have a record that you
can go back and say well she actually
never said this it's just it's it's
impossible the McCain campaign tried but
I don't think it could be done there was
just so much about her background that
it would take months and months and
months and dozens of researchers to
figure out everything she ever said and
did because again she hadn't been in the
public eye before and I will say the
fourth thing is that she didn't help men
matter she exaggerated the truth that a
lot of times there was things she told
John McCain in their early conversations
that turned out to have certain shades
of nuance to them like the fact that you
know she opposed the bridge to nowhere
sort of so it wasn't as if the
Republicans didn't try it's just that
and this may or not may or may not be
interpreted as a slap at Sarah Palin but
they really didn't have they they really
didn't have much to work with that
wasn't actually gonna no I'm gonna
switch gears completely of I mean we
could talk about Sarah Palin
there wasn't I'm just so what I'm
defending is I'm defending the fact that
that it wasn't if they didn't occur to
them that they had to quickly fight the
smears they just they tried and they
couldn't know I really do want to switch
gears okay um Henry asked about some of
the negatives from from the campaign I
want to address three of them and I
think the first to your point was from
resource allocation we were terribly
under-resourced relative to the Obama
campaign
in just pure personnel and I'd like to
sort of I am my lens from this is from
the National Committee not the campaign
so I wasn't privy to a lot of the
decisions that were made but I'll try to
armchair quarterback it a little bit
you'll remember during the primaries
when the campaign was essentially
bankrupt they almost turned off the
lights when when they had to start
making resource decisions I don't think
the internet was the priority when in my
vantage point is a technologist it
probably should have been because that's
where you can be most efficient with
little then there was also that
three-month window between the time the
McCain had effectively wrapped up the
nomination and Obama and Clinton were
duking it out and that was precious time
that I think once again more backend
work could have been done with
technology to better influence the the
race I can't stand scum I can't stand
squatters but we had to we had to spend
so much money around domain names this
cycle for various reasons fight the
smears as a standalone site was it was
interesting I want to give you one
example of what happened one day
perusing Obama's website and there was a
promotion on the home page for meet
Barack Obama and just for kicks I I went
and GoDaddy or somewhere and found that
meet Barack Obama calm was available and
I mean here's meet Barack Obama
promotion on his home page staring you
the face and they didn't acquire that
domain so we went and got it and Henry
if you want to go there you'll see what
we developed from it but it was a
repository of all of our micro sites
that we developed largely to generate
earned media because it was so hard this
cycle to break through the media cycle
that we created com meet meet Barack
Obama but people were you know people
are going people go into search engines
and search me for me Barack Obama
thinking maybe he's going to be in their
town and they stumble across through
are optimized site you know meet Barack
Obama and not until you get to the fine
print at the bottom of the page do you
see that this is a product of the
Republican National Committee but at its
surface it looks innocuous enough and in
fact Barak book looks like something one
might want to click on not knowing that
it's a hit piece and if you go to it
you'll see that it's a faux social
network parody of Facebook which our
opposition research team used to send us
content to basically display Obama's
network of friends and so you can go and
click on Valerie Jarrett and find out
you know what her relationship to Obama
is and who her friends are who their
friends are so um we created a Facebook
app for this and when we updated Barak
booked your Facebook page would update
that there was a so we were trying to
rent things but there are two other
things I want to discuss quickly one is
the unprecedent of money that was
generated online and III by no means say
this to be accusatory but I think both
parties need to take a look at how
moving forward online donations are
going to be utilized and the security
that revolves around it as an example
blue state digital who's responsible for
Obama's fundraising efforts consciously
chose to remove the three security code
requirement from an online donation
which facilitated the ability for gift
cards etcetera I mean you could create a
script that would essentially distribute
by mass by by spoofing your IP address
the resemblance of a donation coming
domestically when it could have come
from a foreign national and and and this
is not unique to the left or the right
is just and I'm not a fan of regulation
but I do think the FEC has an obligation
to start to look at technology in more
demonstrable way as to how campaigns are
receiving donations online and because I
do think that doodad pro just being one
example there were some negatives that
haven't really surfaced yet
lastly getting back to the resources and
the fact that I think there was a
hundred and thirty person strong team on
the Obama side compared
- four on my staff we were getting
comments from McCain supporters who were
saying that they were posting comments
on sites like The Washington Post
and they were being removed and they
couldn't figure out why and we surmised
that what was happening is that people
were going to pro McCain comments on
BBS's and hitting that that comment was
abusive and after enough people did it
those comments were removed so there was
really nothing negative or disparaging
being said about the opposition
it was just using technology smartly to
counter the the other campaign and you
know well done I guess I say one more
thing about the narratives most of the
the readers and I because I did a I did
a poll PIPP so people may be self
responding to the poll but and there are
there are some people in the audience
who I know read the site in command and
and were active commenters or people
emailed me but most of my readers that
80% of them were Barack Obama supporters
and that's disheartening to me because I
wasn't writing a blog for Barack Obama
supporters I was trying to write a
report a blog on politics that that you
know played it as fairly close to what I
saw the truth as is possible in giving
no quarter to either campaign but when
you look at the universe of of websites
there is a significant partisan
clustering effect that goes on even
sites that aren't partisan and the
Atlantic has a series of vloggers I
would say we have two and a half
bloggers that are identifiably
conservative and I'm including Andrew
Sullivan as a half because he's a bit of
a hybrid but Ross Douthat who is
undeniably a wonder brilliant smart
conservative Megan McArdle who is also
very conservative but the majority and
two and a half out of five so that would
be roughly 50/50 but the majority of
people who read the site or who read all
of our blogs including Andrews including
nice watch a walk Ross's were to the
left of center because people tagged the
Atlantic as being part of the old media
the establishment media this the liberal
media online and there were very very
few sites that managed and there been
some studies done about this but very
few websites that managed to straddle
both left-right and then the you know
the small but I think fairly active
group in the center who was just hungry
for information and I don't know how to
solve that but I think that's a problem
because I would have loved to have more
Republican and conservative readers
alright we're gonna open up the
questions in just a minute so people
want to start lining up at the mics but
I'm gonna ask another question they're a
panelist while people are beginning to
formulate questions and get in line so
the question is about governance we've
just come through this campaign we now
have president elect the question is
what are our visions of how new media
can be used for governance people use a
language now permanent campaign so one
notion is that the good stuff that's
gone in the campaign simply continues
and that it takes on a different role
I've just pulled up change.gov which is
the site that the Obama people put up
there very morning after the election
results it's already have office of the
president-elect up up there so what are
you seeing and what are your thoughts
about what's gonna happen now for both
parties as we go into the next four
years if you wouldn't mind I want to
show you a project we created from GOP
calm the platform process where the
party sets basically its objectives for
the next four years has traditionally
been a very offline process you drive to
a hearing you hope that you get to the
microphone to present your thoughts to
the platform committee meetings are held
regionally and so you hope you get to
the microphone you hope that they listen
to what you say you you hope that it
enters the public record and
you know maybe less than one-tenth of
one percent of the nation gets to
participate so so for the first time in
the nation's history we wanted to change
the way in which the party platform
process evolved and if you scroll down
and just so we we opened up the process
for the Republican Party's 2008 platform
and invited any American regardless of
party affiliation to come in and tell us
what they thought the Republican Party
should represent the next four years you
know over half a million people access
the site over 20,000 submissions
both text or video we've incorporated
user submissions into the party platform
and I hope that very similar to change
gov this is the way we we evolve you'll
see on the right-hand column where
Americans haven't have incorporated
their thoughts on what the party
platform should be this guy by the way
the one in the middle I don't know why
he did this but he was submitting
entries all the time but he always did
it from his car at night from his webcam
it didn't make any sense to me but he
submitted thoughts on every plank of the
party platform but but change gov I
think is a very similar effort in in
that we got to begin to I can use phrase
open source government whatever that
means really begin to facilitate this
this dialogue where Americans can truly
contribute to government via via the web
and both the platform project and
change.gov I think are the first efforts
towards that there's a trade-off between
transparency at times and efficiency
that the Obama transition is working out
right now I would hope just for the sake
of accountability that they are on the
side of of transparency but it is very
easy for a White House staff to
well we promised that all the meetings
would be open and we'd say the
participants but we didn't mean this set
or we can't give you a look at what the
Treasury Department how it's actually
allocating its funding even though we
said we would put all the budget online
well we're not going to put all the
defense budget online obviously there
are some things you don't put online but
we're going to put not going to put the
entire department defense there are lots
of choices that the Obama administration
will be forced to make when it comes to
transparency of information which i
think is going to be one of the key ways
in which people using new media hold the
administration accountable and I would
just hope that they again err on the
side of transparency over efficiency
because when they have the power it is
going to be they're gonna be very very
very tempted to close things off to keep
deliberations private and to back away
from from some of Obama's fairly
ambitious campaign promises yeah I would
just say I totally agree with that I
think in fact it's probably the greatest
risk that the millions of people that
supported Obama and honestly even I
think John McCain there's just a
different expectation of the poppy that
the populace is involvement in
governance it's just we've crossed a
line and and we can't unscramble the egg
you know and I actually thought that you
were gonna show Republican for a reason
because I saw that yesterday and I
thought that was a powerful sight
because not only is you know obviously
Obama's change gov and if you go to the
site he's actually asking Americans to
submit their ideas and in fact even the
night his the night of November 4th in
the in the interim period before he was
announced as the winner as
president-elect and before he spoke at
Grant Grant Park there was a massive
email sent out saying thank you this is
all about you I'm going you know
there'll be some new information that
I'll share shortly but he
instantaneously reinforced the message
that look you're still part of this
process but Republican oh I'm sorry it's
right but so clearly on the governance
side I think Obama is going to want to
continue he's got to live up to these
expectations now but I think Republican
for a reason is a good site also and
hopefully it's showing from a Republican
perspective that there's some rebuilding
that needs to be done or you know some
leaders within the Republican party
party think so and so I think this is a
great message as well so it's inviting
Republicans to say look we just lost a
huge election but you know there's still
core principles you know and it's not
just from top down but you as an
individual why don't you re are tick you
late why is it that you're Republican
what are those principles that we stand
for and again start to invite collective
intelligence to help shape the party
from the bottom up so I actually think
this is a great sign from the Republican
Party that you know that there's an
openness to listening to people as
opposed to just you know waiting for
five governors who are in Florida you
know today to suddenly you know come out
with the new you know the the new word
of what the Republican Party will be I
appreciate what my nickname for the site
is eat humble pie calm but you can get
to it at Republican for a reason calm
and anybody can come in and tell us what
they think the Republican Party should
be doing to uh you know cure itself sure
I'm Charlie de tar him and the speech
and mobility group here at the Media Lab
I was wondering if you could comment on
the role in new media technologies and
potentially elevating the discourse in
presidential elections I've noticed that
most of the emails the online videos the
sort of stuff that I saw in this
election still were just tribalistic
soundbite heavy lacking in nuance on any
discussion on issues or policies or the
actual direction government might have
in a more long-term way and can you
comment on the way new media
technologies is there any change any
difference thanks Lois Adama was John
McCain's quote each time he was asked
about negative politics what do you say
right yeah there's always the excuse as
to why he would then launch into these
attacks you know I I you know I don't I
don't think new media is immune to what
is just politics and when you got folks
competing when the stakes are incredibly
high
and by the way you know negative
campaigning works I mean there was a
period of time and again you know in
mid-august you know before the
convention and then right after before
the Democratic convention then right
after the Republican convention there
was a time when Obama McCain I think was
very effective in really going after
Obama's strengths or I was right after
Obama had come back from his European
trip where you know two hundred thousand
folks in Germany you know loved across
the world and he was the greatest
celebrity and the McCain camp it
inspires and Paris Hilton enemies of
course to start to bring down this guy
from this mantle it's all negative
messaging but it was effective and then
the airs the association with Bill Ayers
like that stuff started to work and so
it's it's hard you know III don't know
if new media can solve a problem in fact
I'm sure it can't it just allows more
outlets to get it out but you know
politics is you know presidential
politics is tough business you know I
don't think we can assume that it will
necessarily raise the level of the
discourse one example comes to mind
though about how the Obama campaign was
able to use new media to inject nuance
in that debate remember the gas tax
holiday that Hillary Clinton wanted and
the the the it's a gimmick but in order
to in order to think about the gas tax
holiday is a gimmick you actually have
to think through the arguments for it
because it's not it's not inherently
clear why getting more money back from
the government would simply be a gimmick
when it comes to the gas tax but it was
it was therefore just as someone who
likes intellectual honesty and debates
very heartwarming to read the the
primary exit polls in Indiana where half
of the voters believed that the gas tax
idea was a gimmick and in fact the polls
are replicated across other states and
even at some point some majority of
Americans thought it was gimmick and the
Obama campaign spent a lot of time
through their new media technologies and
emails explaining to people why the gas
tax holiday was was
gimmick and you know at least what that
shows me is that you you don't
necessarily have to you you don't new
media technologies and distribution
channels aren't just limited to very
simple messages that you know that can
touch heartstrings or whatever you can
actually make intellectual arguments and
it was good to see that I mean there
weren't too many examples of that
because it's much easier and and
presumably more effective to you know I
mean I think one of them you know the
Republican National Committee I think
made a very very funny video about about
Obama's celebrity I forgot what I forgot
what it was called but it was it was
very humorous at least in my opinion
it's easier to go to this simple to the
non nuanced but at times or at least at
one time it was used effectively to go
toward the nuance so you know I think if
everyone tries maybe I actually think
new media exacerbates the problem of
negative campaigning and whether it's
the campaign controlling it or not the
fact that the community at large can now
play a part in it and it's such a
decentralized way where the campaign has
no influence over it it just makes it
all the more worse two things well I
guess it in that vein reverent Reverend
Wright's name was off limits I'm Senator
McCain said just you know no way it's
not coming up and it never did from the
campaign but you you found it everywhere
in the blogosphere and the campaign
distance itself from that and when those
comments were posted on the bulletin
boards you know they were they were
removed it was just a taboo subject but
one interesting eye one interesting
thing I saw during the campaign was my
friends Facebook profiles all the
majority of them started to have middle
names and I started to see you know Joe
Hussein Smith on Facebook and I I'd
click on it I've got I've got a vast
group of Facebook friends I don't know a
lot of them but so I'd click on I'd
click on it
and I'd say all right this is a
Republican trying to be cute when in
fact it was Democrats who were just
mocking the fact that Obama's middle
name was being mocked and I I'd love to
know from Facebook how many people
actually had Hussein in their name I
mean it must have been in the millions
but it was just an interesting you so
it's like a cool thing for Democrats to
do on Facebook but it's spread by yeah
it's spread it was pretty wild to watch
we had at the center for future Civic
media yesterday a speaker who's been
scanning the blogosphere for keywords
and found that they were overwhelmingly
more references to Hussein on liberal
blogs than on conservative blogs so that
in fact liberals spent more time
responding to that that criticism or
that tactic than the tactic itself was
played out over here hi I'm gossamer
North student northeastern actually and
a couple of my friends that have who
saying middle name on their Facebook in
the past couple weeks and what I'm
wondering is I saw I'm not too sure what
this was but I think I read that the
Obama campaign or the Obama
administration might be using a website
of its own to as a channel of
information going directly to the public
which would bypass any kind of media
outlet and how so that's if you have any
thoughts on that and how do you think
the new administration might use new
media in discovering in general well
they've said several things one of which
is they're going to Obama wants to
incorporate a daily weekly YouTube
address as opposed to a you know a
weekly radio address radio radio being
the traditional format for it the White
House will probably establish some sort
of a blog whether that will include
comments is TBD because there's a lot of
stuff you have to think through the
Obama one of the things that he has said
he would do is and again this will come
at the expense of the efficiency of
these but he wants to open all
regulatory hearings put them on a
centralized website and allow people to
comment on regulatory hearings in real
time and force the people who are
administering the regulations to read
all the comments again there's a
difference with the efficiency and
transparency you can see how that you
know the the trade-off there and one of
the one of the other things that there
can
littering is in something that the the
government of the UK has already
instituted which is sort of a I think
it's petitions UK gov where citizens can
launch their own petition drives that in
theory someone at 10 Downing Street will
read every single petition they can be
either jocular or they can be serious
you haven't heard too much about it in
the UK in part because they haven't
quite figured out or they're not quite
prepared to accept the ramifications of
allowing a citizen petition process but
I know that is something the Obama folks
are are considering as well whether they
do any of this I'm you know I'm not sure
but but he talked about some of this in
in in during the campaign and and and I
do know that that they're thinking about
these things right now and you know one
of the one of the things we're hearing
and I think it would be just tremendous
is that they're considering creating a
chief technology officer cabinet level
position which and so you know that I
think is transformative and I think they
were talking to Eric Schmidt of Google
too and I guess he's publicly denied but
maybe he moaned who knows but it's hard
to say no so that I think would be
extraordinary because it would it would
essentially you know make every area of
government put under the microscope of
how can technology be utilized to make
it more efficient right so whether it's
education health care all these
different ideas make technology at the
center and I think I'm really hoping
that that's actually a big sort of
single huge message that you know
because the cabinet you know
historically you know that's where the
that's where the heavy hitters are
that's who's has access to the president
and a and a CTO who has accountability
across all of these different divisions
I think really would be huge
but if they are other people who are
encouraged so to repeat the question for
the podcast audience and others the
question had to do with we've sort of
had a lot of discussion around new media
and young voters water if we move toward
new media what are the implication for
older voters who often have lagged
behind in their embrace of new
technologies is that as well I mean it's
a geographic split urban areas tend to
be more wired or wireless than rural
areas both candidates well it doesn't
matter what John McCain promised now
because he's not Obama where I be is big
of right that's he's bigoted right
elevations they both promised
significant expansions significant
expenditures on broadband sir broadband
services for rural areas but there's
there has to be a revolution in
technology Padma I confess I'm not an
expert here and there probably people in
the audience who know much more about it
than I do but there has to be an
enormous regulatory revolution and
Technology Policy in order for there to
be truly Universal broadband in this
country and however not so I think part
of it is I think part of part of that's
the obstacle but
seemed to be something that this
administration is aware of I don't know
if that's probably not a good enough
answer for you and it is a problem
certainly but you know I think I'm not
confident that well maybe I am Kaiba
just the this is still an area where
again we're we're technology companies
and tell telecoms and spend enormous
amounts to lobby and there's the every
couple years in Congress there are these
extremely complicated telecom bills that
push things in one direction or another
and I guess it'll just take some
something to dislodge that in order for
us to get to the point where we're again
we could truly have some sort of a
universal broadband network across the
country which I do think is kind of the
only way to facilitate access for
everyone harry shearer has a wonderful
radio show where he has a segment where
irregularly pokes holes and the idea
that this digital transition is going to
be smooth the one in you know in
February when analog television no
longer works and the government will say
well we spend a lot of money trying to
educate people but if you look at the
response rates of people who we know
have analog TV sets are actually sending
in for coupons to buy digital digital
conversion boxes it's it's fairly low so
I don't I don't have any answers I just
I agree that it's complete a problem
yeah you know circle which is the group
that hmm measures youth voting just
released the fact that in this 2008
election the number of 18 to 29 year
olds that voted for the first time in at
least two decades was greater than the
number of people 65 and over and it may
actually be the greatest number ever but
there's they're looking at they're
looking at years prior to two decades
but you know you're you're right I mean
in some ways it's similar to the
challenge of when we had all sorts of
say shion's about the digital divide you
know you had whole groups of low-income
communities that were not part of the
process and so how could we expect them
to engage and this is why I think for me
it comes back to a CTO type position or
getting you know 100 100 percent
broadband penetration we actually need a
presidential team that recognizes the
importance of enabling technologies for
everyone not just for you know those
that can you know afford broadband but I
think it does come down to that but
you're right I mean you know young
people again partly because of the new
technologies part of the campaign part
of the strategy they are utilizing and
taking advantage of all this stuff in
much bigger numbers than older folk and
we can only hope that this
administration recognizes that it's not
good to leave now that segment behind
where you know we've left other segments
behind to you know to ill effect over
the coming years from a whoa
from a sociological standpoint there's
actually a really large audience of
older web users but where they're
falling behind technologically is in the
advancement of you know 2.0 and I mean
look at yawns which is nowhere on the
map from network standpoint relative you
know to Facebook but this was a point I
made at the outset of the campaign which
was we're so enamoured now with the chic
sites Twitter etc that we've forgotten
about the millions of users that are on
the portals AOL MSN Yahoo even and from
my experience they're you know they're
in the older users are there in droves
but they're not where you'd think they
are they're on the gaming sites which on
face value seems contradictory but
they're playing backgammon and cribbage
on MSN games and
trying to find Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett I guess but it's I think it's
just the adoption of the evolution of
technology but I'd argue that there's
actually a pretty sizable older audience
online
hello I'm Madeline Ellis I'm a graduate
student here at CMS my question forgive
me if it's a little cynical that often
seems to be my role here but um we've
been talking a lot about user Act active
users engaged users and I'm just
wondering if we really are to take what
has happened as a universally rosy
picture or if more it on the surface it
seems like users are driving the
conversation but there really is a lot
of thought taken to manipulating the
conversation from the campaign's and
from media outlets and sort of as as
insiders if you could give us your view
on on that negotiation that's happening
what would be an example do you think of
manipulation that you've seen no if I
can think of anything at the exact
moment but give me a minute I don't know
if my question is vaguely mentioned Joe
the Plumber McCain campaign attempted to
make Joe the Plumber sort of a universal
stand-in for everyman there was a web
campaign you know show us how your Joe
the Plumber remember the commercial I'm
Joe the Plumber I'm Joe the Plumber I'm
Joe the Plumber there was certainly a
lot of attention paid to Joe the Plumber
but and and the McCain campaign did its
best to drive that and the media paid a
lot of attention to it and the American
people didn't seem to so it might be an
example of how the media I I acknowledge
I mean this again was because both
candidates instantly mentioned the guy's
name what 40 times total in the debate
in some sense the story led the media to
say who is this Joe the Plumber guy but
the effect that Joe the Plumber had in
the election
unfortunately for the McCain campaign
was was fairly minimal so maybe there's
an example of how in this fragmented age
the media can try to set an agenda or
collectively not try because there's no
I can tell if there is a conference call
I am NOT on it and I want to be on it
because you know I work in these areas
but you know just the collective
mentality the media certainly focused on
Joe the Plumber and then on you know the
fact that he wasn't a licensed on all
this stuff didn't didn't seem to matter
that much but maybe one example of how
the media did didn't the old media did
matter was in in helping people or
helping people come to a different
perception of Sarah Palin than they had
initially you know the the succession of
interviews that she did I mean III again
I'm a consultant for CBS News but the
way that CBS News extent Katie Couric
had about 45 minutes with Sarah Palin
over the course of two days and CBS
broke the interview into three or four
minute chunks and ran it over a week and
it did seem like every single day there
was an additional question now all the
questions I should say I think are
entirely defensible from the standpoint
of asking them but every day it seemed
to be a more outrageous question that
she didn't that she didn't get and I
have heard the argument that that was
CBS trying to manipulate people's
impression of Sarah Palin I disagree
with that but that might be something
you know what you're something to the
degree that what your well your
discussion people with in campaigns who
go on and pretend that they're users in
order to drive the conversation or we
actually reference once people taking
down comments and enabling people to
cancel comments I guess sort of I think
that stuff happens on on the on the
extreme margins of noting that people
are extreme it happens on the
real margins of their to be the people I
guess the sock puck sock puppets is the
technical phrase for them and I mean
that always do there's some you know
usually just individual dumb person on a
campaign thinks they can be cute by
pretending to do X Y & Z and because
it's so it's people are fairly easily
exposed it would
things are fairly easy exposed so I
don't I don't think that that was much
well let me give you a concrete example
one of the most heavily hit visited
Wikipedia entries of all time with Sarah
Palin's entry the day of her
announcement and if you follow the
history page back it looked like between
sixty to seventy percent of the content
there was written between midnight and
noon and the day of the announcement
right well let's say we don't know who
wrote that but circumstantial evidence
suggests it was probably someone in the
campaign now whether we see that as
manipulation or simply that's good I
would see that as good campaigning but
some casitas and I can see what you're
saying I mean you obviously you you want
to try and define Sarah Palin positively
if you're the McCain campaign and if you
don't do that you know it's a hard
question because I just see a political
campaign is essentially a manipulation
of media you know it's it's so I'm a
little hard pressed to answer because it
you know the campaigns are trying to
tell a story and they're gonna create
you know very effective ways to
manipulate all the different ways you're
going to hear that story you know on all
the different platforms so yeah I think
so too the your question I think yes I
think it is very much complete
manipulation of media to tell your story
you know it's it's I mean that's the
deal I mean that's that's you gotta win
an election this is all this story just
very briefly martin aizen's this this
this the the there actually is an
example now this guy named or fake guys
not doesn't exist but this person a few
people created an identity forgot named
martin Eisenstaedt who they claimed was
a mccain adviser who had fed Carl a
Cameron of Fox the quote that that you
know Sarah Palin couldn't distinguish
between a couldn't didn't know whether
Africa was a thought Africa was a
country as opposed to a continent and a
lot of media sources uncritically pick
this up and said oh you know this is the
McCain and they didn't even bother to
check that this person the McCain
campaign really had no idea who this
person was was an advisor but again
these things get exposed so quickly
right I think probably what's
interesting about that example
is because the original quote came from
a report a reporter on Fox that was
critical of Sarah Palin you
instantaneously believed it was true
right because Fox has such a reputation
of only reporting positive news that
it's like well who needs to check
there's no right box but if Keith
Olbermann said something bad about
Barack Obama you'd be like you know
right it has to be true so anyway so I
mean there are so to that degree if that
if that's what falls in the category of
manipulation of media no doubt what what
Keith Olbermann does every night at
eight o'clock and what Sean Hannity does
at 9:00 p.m. every night that is
complete bias on both sides of the aisle
technologically we're facilitating this
through tools like mash-up technology I
mean you can now mash up mash ups and
mash those up and so what begins as a
pure campaign originated video takes on
a life of its own by the very fact you
put it on YouTube so the the
manipulation we're facilitating it I
guess I'm gonna add another facet to
Madeleine's
kind of cynicism I come from a
background in very traditional activism
and have a lot of old-school hippie
friends from the 60s who are very
disturbed by what they're seeing with
Barack Obama and I keep hearing the the
phrase cult of personality things like
this you know I don't I don't believe it
but this is what I'm hearing from my
older friends and at the same time I
they're criticizing the kind of things
that you're pointing out here where it's
like you just put a widget on your blog
and you feel like you've done something
that's active and involved and changing
policy and I'm wondering what you have
to say about that first of all and
second of all I'm wondering what you
have to say about this also from the
point of view that the very same people
who have been saying about bush for last
eight years that you know he's someone
that I want to go have a beer with and
you know he's just like us are now
saying the same things about Barack
Obama where it's like you know
scholar he's one of us we feel very we
feel very comfortable with him and I'm
not I'm not saying that's necessarily a
bad thing to be believing about your
candidates in fact I think it's a great
thing that people are feeling connected
with their candidates but at the same
time I'm wondering if the kind of tools
that we've been talking about have
changed how we approach our politics
rather from a instead of from a policy
perspective we're coming at it now from
a kind of like who's who's our who's our
man kind of or woman perspective I I
think I think it is I think it is
although I would love to ask what you
call your hippie friends if if if they
had if they felt a certain reverence for
John F Kennedy during the 60s if he was
became this larger-than-life mythical
figure who represented so much and then
we had Watergate and all these you know
so I I would I would I would be curious
how they would compare their personal
feelings for him - what's happening with
Obama now but I do think there's I mean
we live in a celebrity culture a lot of
it fueled by MTV where you know there is
this this idea that we can be you know I
can have a hundred you know 300 friends
and sent aeneas Lee yeah you know I can
create these intimate relationships so
you're right there is a different I
don't know if it's necessarily bad I
mean I do think for our audience I do
think that you know that they there is a
certain kind of kinship with Obama but
there's no doubt that issues played a
big role I mean 74 percent of 18 to 29
year olds told us that they personally
know someone that fought in Iraq or
Afghanistan you know a huge issue in
terms of seeing your friends independent
of how you felt felt about the war but
knowing that who is president has a date
has a real impact on your lives and so
when our audience is telling us they're
seeing their friends come home and not
getting the treatment they deserve or
not getting their school benefits or
they can't hold a job where they can't
stay in a relationship that became a
very real issue for them and seeing gas
prices and knowing that we're at war
because of our you know dependence on
oil so so while there certainly is a I
think there is a cult of personality I
don't think that
pletely trumped issues like a massive
deficit you know stock markets plunging
fears are on global warming so you know
we have to give some credit to you know
that this will also is an issues based
election how deeply do you think the
people that you were working with were
engaged with issues because you know
Barack Obama has prompt promise to
increase military spending and you know
in various issues this is the people who
I'm working with are saying there's a
disconnect between this ideal of him is
a strong anti-war candidate and I share
those people's concerns but what he's
promising on the policy side and I'm
that's that's the kind of disconnect I'm
curious the bright point out he's always
said he's always denied that he's an
anti work and what he will say is I'm
against the Iraq war I'm not against war
right and and instantly actually both at
me and at this point now he's he's he
he's talking about cutting defense
spending but that's because everyone's
talking about cutting defense spending
but that's a tangential point but I I
just I just wanted to clear that up
because maybe Pia I think part of the
the genius of the Obama campaign was
that he allowed a lot of different
things to be projected onto him and
maybe that also you know could turn out
to be if he doesn't do very well his
undoing because expectations for him may
be very very different maybe not in the
reality of increasing increasing
increasing activism has improved through
technology because we're we're making it
easier and import I think most important
geographically because if you're from a
small town you can convene with a
close-knit group of people but we've
broaden that ability as an example you
know at least on our social networking
Obama had the same functionalities you
can really get into my new show of how
you want to become an activist by you
know I care about these issues this is
how I'm willing to help support these
issues whether it's door knocking or
phone banking etc and I just think
that's increasing the body of people
that want to participate which which is
a good thing you you've opened a huge
door for me that I'm not sure I want to
go into on criticizing Obama but I think
the one point
the one point that we were trying to
make this campaign that I'm not really
sure ever resonated was that we don't
know a lot about Senator Obama and I
mean I hope he's a great president I
hope America becomes stronger and we
solve our economic issues but we really
know so little about him at the time and
time time will tell about it strip out
his true self we see the image of
because I feel like all information is
out there it's just that people aren't
connecting with it they're connecting
with other elements but I don't want to
take up too much all right yeah so we
are we're about to go into what I call
the lightning round session we've got 15
minutes late we have a hard stop at the
top of the hour so everyone can try for
conciseness on both sides of the
microphones here we can hopefully get at
least these people waiting in line yeah
I'll try to pack this all into it to a
quick sound bite but my name is Evan and
I I helped start and I've been working
on research for a site called glass
booth org for the past year some of you
guys might have seen it but it's a
nonpartisan not profit not-for-profit
voter education site where we really
tried to get all of the candidates and
their positions on not just mainstream
issues like Iraq and abortion but also
different issues like net neutrality or
media consolidation or sort of the
principle of war as an instrument of
policy different types of questions and
really making that information
transparent so my question is about the
debates and with the debates this year
you saw them start to open up in the
sense they had the CNN YouTube debate
there was the thing on MTV where there
was a citizen submitting questions but
they didn't really go all the way there
was still a control maintained over the
questions and because of that you never
really got questions asked in the public
sphere about questions like media
consolidation or drug policy or these
sort of marginalize issues so I'm just
wondering I guess how you think the
control over the debates is changing and
and how much longer you think sort of
corporations and also the two major
parties can keep that control and how
soon they're going to have to sort of
let citizens really choose the questions
that are asked well I I get paychecks
from corporations so I'm I'm
you can disbelieve this response of
course but I spent a lot of time on the
campaign trail and in virtually every
college town that both candidates were
asked they were always ask at least one
question about drug policy
happened in 2004 when all the candidates
I mean is so questions certainly ask the
candidates had stock responses to it
because the questions were we're usually
you know we're usually similar and they
they took positions on things like net
neutrality and they and I you know you
would hear the mass about media
consolidation but you're right I mean I
don't I don't think you're ever going to
convince the old media so you sent that
they they have control of these settings
completely relinquish it I mean that
Ralph Nader has certainly been trying
for years and years and years by trying
to get into these debates I mean I I do
I do think that Commission on
presidential debates probably for
different reasons than you do but I
think it's a complete and utter joke and
that you know that the candidates I mean
that it's a private corporation that
essentially has I mean and that that
does actually create concerns for me a
private corporation having control over
these very very very important moments
of of our of our democracy so I think
you and I may disagree about corporate
media for a variety of different levels
but I think perhaps we can we can both
agree that the Commission on
presidential debates is one thing that
that and there's a lot of complex
reasons why I think it's an awful idea
but it is it is a bit disconcerting to
have a private corporation control what
are the just even the format and the
rules so the candidates say that they
negotiate them it's a don't hey I'm not
gonna talk more about this because it's
a very sore issue for for me but they
are kind of ridiculous I hope they go
away I just want to echo marks
sentiments and say that that for me was
the most disappointing part of this
entire campaign cycle was that the
Presidential Commission on debates did
such a poor job of incorporating
technology and bringing in the voices of
the citizens to participate in something
that was archaic um on its face I mean
it this is a call out look at the camera
it's a call to whoever leads the
organization to please in the next set
of debates improve yeah when we when we
did our first big event with Senator
Obama an MTV MySpace we partnered and by
the way glass booth is a great website
and I wish we had done more work with
you when we did our first MTV myspace
presidential dialogue with Senator Obama
we partnered with a group called ten
questions comm and the basic idea with
ten questions was that people submitted
the question that they wanted to ask the
president and or the home they wanted to
ask the candidate and we said look at at
10:30 on the morning that we were doing
the dialogue which is happening at 12
o'clock the number one question at 10:30
would be the question that was asked and
it turned out to be uh net neutrality
yeah that's we that's where we got
Obama's position actually is from you
guys so never worked that might before
Hey
okay so uh what do you think about
Barack's not having any kind of military
experience I mean certainly he's not
qualified to be the president if he
doesn't have any military experiment
okay not exactly a media question I
don't know if anyone wants to oh well
you know the election went on and I
thought we were talking about the
election and media results represent
this question of experience which was
certainly a central theme running
through the campaign well especially
when compared to someone who had the
incredible background of John McCain I
mean it was a it was a big
differentiating characteristic that I
don't think you know I think John McCain
didn't do a good enough job of drawing
that distinction but I think what Obama
was able to do okay so you think that
McCain didn't have military experience
not for it wounded him in his campaign
but because Obama kind of
could you battle or something that made
him equal McCain Amana know how far we
want to go down this road but McCain
right I mean my sense is in this on this
particular issue
if the Iraq war if the Iraq war had
remained as big an issue as it was a
year ago the sort of preponderance on
military background and military acumen
probably would have made much more of a
difference ultimately the campaign
became much more about the ability to be
a you know a steward over the economy
and I think on that front McCain didn't
you know in the military experience the
hero the heroines of all that stuff just
became much less important and so I
think it just became a non-issue
even though McCain certainly had you
know much more cred in that area okay
I've got eight minutes to get to
questions in so why don't we if you'd
let us go to the next question
why did media so completely dropped the
issue of Obama producing his birth
certificate since the two most important
qualifiers for presidency is age and the
place of birth is that do you think the
only reason it work they're completely
never dropped dropped it completely
because he was black and they were
afraid of being accused what you're
saying you're saying yeah the story that
he was important we still don't know if
he's an American or not we should go to
fight the smears calm and sin see if
it's there seriously I mean that that's
definitely been a rumor that he wasn't
born in the United States and in fact
the truth matters I think he has but
that has the truth has nothing to do
with this right and and because in fact
when when he was quote-unquote suspended
his campaign and a much more elegant
style than McCain suspended his campaign
but when he went back to Hawaii for to
visit his sick grandmother that was the
rumor was that was all a cover you know
for him to go back and burn
and documents that actually really oh
there it is there it is and if it's on
the internet it's got to be true that's
again that's the power of what this
campaign has done but here's what do you
believe that do you think that's a valid
having seen that because because it's
what would it take to convince you
no I'm serious because obviously the
Obama campaign is putting this out you
could say well this is their fabrication
but but the one question in this age of
all this stuff is you know what type of
authority does it take to convince
people even though it does seem too you
know you can never approach 100% of the
of the so but I've met Matt maybe it's
it's not answerable question yeah I mean
David David is just noting that it
probably no other point in human history
would we have answered this question
quickly as we've done here whether we
believe or trust the information on the
toilet our nots a legitimate question
and I began information on memo size is
readily available at a fingertip and
scores just scroll up just scroll up see
what the look what the directive says at
the top next time someone talks about
Barack's birth certificate make sure
they see this page it's amazing it is
okay do you guys have final comments
meaning we haven't talked on that you
think central to our understanding of
this topic nice so yeah the question is
fundraising in the new media what are we
talked in a little bit but clearly it's
one of the big implications of this
campaign is one of the big
transformation is how much money how
it's possible to process smaller scale
donors and what some of the implications
of that may be yeah the truth is I'm I'm
really excited by it this this whole
idea of you actually take it out of the
political context for a second
this idea of micro philanthropy it's
really you know there are they are it
presents enormous opportunity
if you look at websites like kiva.org
some of you might be familiar with Kiva
or GlobalGiving
these are sites that essentially allow
an individual to make a personal
connection to another individual
individual in the case of kiva.org it is
an entrepreneur in a developing country
that might need a micro loan of $250 but
you know in their home country that that
is an enormous amount of money that then
allows them to launch a thriving
business that can transform their family
and so much as from what has been
learned from senator Obama's campaign is
how to facilitate these kinds of
connections where you essentially
eliminate intermediaries and another
thing that's been really amazing about
Kiva is that you know the the payback
rate is some of the extraordinary like
98% of the loans that are made or paid
back which is amazing but not only that
when the founders of Kiva launched they
thought they would just be helping the
entrepreneurs who now got access to
capital
but they've discovered that they've
created a community amongst the people
who are loaning the money who are now
saying wow you know I put money into
this business in Peru but do you know
that there's an an entrepreneur in
Uruguay who's got a similar kind of
business so I think you know outside of
the political context I think there are
enormous opportunities in education you
know we're working with with the Gates
Foundation on an idea now to facilitate
you know the idea of creating a
scholarship marketplace where any
individual can make a donation in the
form of a scholarship to a young person
who's who's at risk of dropping out of
high school it's it's it's tremendous I
think what it could mean for solving
really intractable problems by tapping
into the goodwill of individuals all
across the world I just like to
reiterate what I said earlier about the
importance of being a sport right as
possible about your donors and the ease
in which the Obama campaign enabled
small dollar donations I think it's
great that as many Americans donated
presumably Americans donated as they did
but I think it's presumably I think it's
incumbent I think it's incumbent that
moving forward I mean there was there
was no transparency
on Obama's website as to their donors
the RNC the RNC provided a database
where you could search for any donor Ron
Paul provided the names of all of his
donors as did Mike Huckabee on his web
on their websites so and the response
from the Obama campaign that it was
gonna be too difficult to sift through
the donors to determine who was valid
and who wasn't when in fact visa
processes millions of more donations per
hour than the Obama campaign did in
their entire campaign and the print the
the the the response at its surface um
wasn't acceptable to me well maybe I'll
end by by acknowledging that the McCain
campaign was more transparent about that
and some of the Obama campaign's
responses were were silly and that
Barack Obama and this may be getting to
what what you want to talk about and
that Barack Obama you know did decide to
opt out of the public financing system
because he simply believed that he could
raise a lot more money and and did in
his mind justified to the fact that
saying well if I can get two million
people to give that's kind of public
financing it's not a bunch of people but
not not a you know not a smaller group
of folks but Obama has also promised to
support a bill that would mandate public
financing for presidential elections
kind of easy to do that once you've been
elected but he's promised to do that and
and he obviously was successful not
doing that so it'll be very interesting
to see whether he keeps that promise or
whether he or whether he tries to wiggle
out of it now I'm gonna go a little
hyper partisan because you brought that
up Obama did promise that that he was
gonna take financing and then when he
saw the potential the internet and how
much money was coming in he he'd a back
off of his word and now that he's
elected promising to change it to so
it's it's hypocritical oh well it's it's
something but he you know he he did I
mean he deeply saw I mean even if even
Obama partisans should acknowledge that
the decision topped it was a wonderful
instrumental and tactical moment for his
campaign but ethic or now I wouldn't say
ethically but it wasn't the best moment
when it comes to you know sort of the
keeping his camp keeping his promises so
it's clear the debates about this
campaign will continue for a long time
to come but this has been an
illuminating discussion and I appreciate
all of the panelists and the audience
participation so thanks everyone for a
great
[Applause]